today on the Matt wall show Americans
continue to drop out of the workforce at
an alarming Pace this is part of a
general decline that includes Church
attendance and marriage rates what is
behind all of this and how much of it is
is the leftover effect of the covid
shutdowns we'll talk about that today
also Republicans add another election
loss to their tally Time Magazine shocks
no one with their person of the year
selection a grand jury report proves
that the sex abuse Scandal Loudoun
County is way worse than we thought
California makes plans to deliver
reparations and a woke tick-tocker
explains why white people should seek
permission before hanging out with black
people it's very important advice all of
that and more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
you know Roe v Wade has been overturned
and this battle is now finally leaving
DC and going to the Grassroots no group
in America is better positioned than 40
Days for life with about 1 million
Volunteers in a thousand cities 40 Days
for life holds peaceful visuals outside
of abortion facilities they have a
larger presence in blue states with
California being their largest state
some former abortion facility directors
say these vigils can cause the abortion
no show rate to go as high as 75 which
is detrimental to their abortion
business these law-abiding vigils have
closed many abortion businesses in
America and nearly half of those closed
abortion facilities were in Liberal
cities where abortion will remain legal
including closures in San Francisco
Chicago and Seattle 40 Days for life is
effectively changing hearts and Minds in
the Grassroots to end abortion you can
check out their locations podcasts and
free magazine at 40daysforlife.com the
Fight Continues it is not over so it's
so important for you to get engaged and
for more information again to go to
40daysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com
well back in 2020 as we all recall and
we'll never forget until the day we die
governments across the world forced
citizens into their homes closed our
workplaces our churches our schools
everything and invented arbitrarily a
stifling series of rules and regulations
to govern anyone who still dared to
venture outside of their homes and
gather around other human beings if they
dared they tried to muzzle our faces
they told us how many feet were supposed
to stay separated from each other they
did all this out of some combination of
panic and competence and of course
premeditated malice and opportunism I
don't really need to recount the story I
realize we all lived through it and
recently
but even as most of the insane
anti-human anti-freedom coveted policies
have fallen away
somehow we are still living through that
period perpetually the vestiges of the
covid days remain people retreated into
their homes
and out of society
and it would seem a certain large
portion of those people never came out
they never returned a writer named
Matthew Stoller pointed to the problem
in a tweet yesterday that got some
attention he said I hear from right-wing
small business owners that employees are
just not showing up and I also hear from
left-wing professors that students are
just not showing up this Dynamic got
much worse during covid something is
very off Church attendance is down crime
is up labor force participation is down
life spans are down drug overdoses are
up I don't know what's going on but it's
not good now the numbers bear out what
he's talking about the Wall Street
Journal reports in just one aspect of
this problem uh report this week says
the labor Department's November jobs
report on Friday certainly didn't make
the federal reserve's anti-inflation
task any easier strong job and wage
growth suggests demand for workers still
exceeds the supply and inflation is
still too high notwithstanding reports
of layoffs in Silicon Valley plenty of
businesses are hiring the problem is
they still can't find enough workers
it's not merely a result of more baby
boomers retiring labor Force
participation among males ages 25 to 54
has slid to 88.4 percent from 89.3
before the pandemic the decline is most
pronounced among young men labor
participation among males ages 20 to 24
has fallen 1.7 percentage points since
January 2020 versus 0.5 for those ages
45 to 54 and if these sound like small
percentage points keep in mind we're
talking about over the course of just a
couple of years and also keep in mind
1.7 percent of males ages 20 to 24 you
know the actual raw numbers here are
very large
so the labor shortage is a real problem
it's not just among young men
this is a nationwide all demographics
issue and as a piece on fortune.com says
uh reported last week it's it's a
problem that is probably here to stay
because whatever's driving it now
declining birth rates mean that
eventually there simply won't be enough
young able-bodied human beings left to
fill all the jobs that's because the
societal withdrawal that we're going
through extends far beyond the labor
market people aren't just refusing to go
and get jobs they're also refusing to
get married they're refusing to have
babies they refuse them to start
families all the things that we talk
about in this show all the time this to
go along with yes the drastically
declining Church attendance and
religious affiliation
everything seems to be on the decline
except drug overdoses and suicides those
are steadily climbing
so something is going on yes uh we are
seeing a mass Retreat an epidemic of
self-isolation unlike anything that
we've ever encountered before
Mass numbers of people have dropped out
of society not in the sense of like
burning their driver's license and
Hiking into the Alaskan Wilderness like
Chris McCandless and Into the Wild
that's that's a much more respectable
sort of dropping out it's at least fully
committed so you can respect that our
dropouts are different they're not you
know out hunting for game in the forest
they're in their homes or someone's home
maybe their parents enjoying all the
luxuries of modern society watching TV
using their phones scrolling the
internet ordering doordash playing video
games yet they're not participating in
society they're living off of society
they are not contributing to it
that's the kind of Dropout we're talking
about
so why why is this happening I began by
talking about the coveted shutdowns
and there is no question that they
played an enormous role in bringing us
to our current state the shutdowns can
be partially blamed for really
everything that happens in our culture
from here on out because they were that
kind of pivotal moment in our history
everything is different now because of
them nothing has been left untouched
nothing is the same
the shutdowns had an incredibly
demoralizing effect on the population
the vast majority of us were declared
non-essential and not just in our jobs
but nearly every part of our Lives all
of the parts that we live and experience
outside of our homes
were designated non-essential you were
told that uh it's not essential to go to
work it's not essential to go to school
it's not essential to go to church it's
not essential to go to the park with
your kids it's not essential to go to
the beach it's not essential to gather
together with your family around the
holidays it's not essential to sit by
your grandmother's bed and hold her hand
while she dies
it's not essential to see the faces of
strangers that you pass by on the
streets it's not essential for them to
see yours
and I think
part of what's Happening Here is that
many people took all this to Heart
and though most of them have re-entered
Society to some extent since then the
message settled into their minds into
their souls that none of this matters
none of it's essential all that matters
is that you keep breathing that you
Linger on
and as long as you're fed and sheltered
and entertained you should be perfectly
satisfied with that and if you get to
the point where you're not satisfied
with that anymore well then you take the
way out the way out that Canada if you
live in Canada is perfectly willing to
facilitate for you whether you have a
terminal illness or not
so as a people
it would seem that generally speaking we
learned all the wrong lessons from covid
I mean it could have been a time of
radical reorientation you know of like
refocusing on the things that truly
matters matter of of confronting our
mortality of the you know the fragility
of human existence
committing ourselves to living full
lives with purpose and meaning
that's not what happened societally
instead the word came down from the top
from the powers that be
and it resounded in the minds of so many
in the population too many that you
don't need purpose or meaning or joy in
your life you don't need other people
you don't need relationships
you don't need family
you need simply four walls and a roof to
exit to exist inside of and enough
gadgets to keep you distracted
but we cannot let our analysis ignore
the fact that all of the troubling
trends that we're highlighting here were
also present before covet
so yes covet plays a role in all of this
just like it's going to play a role in
in
everything as I said that happens from
here on out because it was that sort of
moment
the virus or our response to the virus
rather accelerated the trends Amplified
them gave them a kind of turbocharged
boost but it didn't create these
problems out of whole cloth without
covid we would have ended up probably
where we are now except perhaps maybe it
would have taken us another 20 years to
get here
so what lies
at the root of it all well
there's a reason why we as a society
learn the wrong lessons from our
experiences over the last couple of
years it's because the wrong lessons are
the same ones that have been drilled
into our heads by the culture from birth
it's um it's the message that our kids
being are being taught it's a message of
nihilism
you know that's what lies at the heart
of all this
people aren't working or they aren't
working hard remember the the you know
the so-called quiet quitting Trend very
popular Trend which is part of this
story too
it's not just people not going to work
there are also lots of people going to
work and just but they don't care
anymore
uh so they're doing that they're not
getting married uh they aren't going to
church
wasting their lives looking at their
damn phones
because they don't see meaning in
anything they they are simply biting
time until they die they treat life like
a waiting room just amuse yourself until
your name is called except that they
believe we're waiting for nothing so our
name will be called and will be ushered
into Oblivion we come from nothing we'll
become nothing again which means that we
are fundamentally nothing right now and
nothing means anything nothing matters
that's at the heart of this
all that matters is deriving pleasure
from wherever you can derive it satisfy
your desires satiate your ego
you know this also explains the right I
said I said everything's declining
except suicide and Drug overdoses the
other thing rather you know the other
thing Rising though is LGBT
identification
that's because people are looking for
you know their identity in their in
their in their um in their sexual
proclivities
to satisfy yourself pleasure that's all
that matters there's nothing more to do
in life
there's nothing more to offer
and leads nowhere in the end so hop on
your phone scroll and scroll keep
yourself distracted
until the lights go out and I think a
large number of people are are satisfied
with that kind of life or at least if
they're not satisfied they have resigned
themselves to it this life of
nothingness
so where do we go from here
well there is no solution there's no
hope outside of what we really need
which is a full spiritual Revival I mean
we spend too much time dancing around
the edges of the cultural rot
we need to confront it down in the in
the darkest depths at its core
you know the parts of this problem
nobody wants to look at it's pretty
depressing
if you go down all the way down there to
the core you find that it's totally
empty there's a giant Cavern that needs
to be filled with something
and what is that something truth
you know with meaning with faith
with God
now let's get to our five headlines
well the lack of a red wave during the
midterms lead to more Reckless spending
by a more emboldened Administration
higher taxes maybe deeper inflation if
you're unsure how the next two years
will unfold talk to Birch gold group
about protecting your savings with gold
Birch gold makes it easy to convert your
IRA or 401K into an IRA and precious
metals so you can own gold and silver
and attack sheltered account gold is the
world's oldest most proven form of
currency when inflation soars and all
other assets go sideways gold is still
there this month you can get a free gold
gold back with every five thousand
dollar purchase when you convert an
existing Ira or 401K into a precious
metals Ira with Birch gold by December
22nd just text Walsh to 98 98 98 Birch
gold will help you own gold and silver
in a tax sheltered account text Walsh to
98 98 98 to claim your free info kit on
gold then talk to one of their precious
metals Specialists with every purchase
you make before December 22nd you'll get
a free gold back that is a great
stocking stuffer just in time for
Christmas so you got to text Wall Street
98 98 98 and protect yourself with gold
today
all right so we uh begin the five
headlines with some more great election
news for the Republicans hooray
um daily wire has the report Senator
Rafael Warnock has defeated Republican
challenge rehearsal Walker in Georgia's
2022 Senate runoff election
decision desks headquarters called the
race at approximately 9 48 PM neither
Walker nor wanna Warnock secured more
than 50 percent of the vote during the
general election thus triggering the
runoff election held on Tuesday
warnock's Victory follows a
disappointing midterm election from
Republicans across the country aside
from several bright spots in the Georgia
and Florida gubernatorial uh races
many pre-med term polls and analyzes
predicted a red wave we know about that
this is warnock's second runoff after he
defeated GOP candidate uh Kelly loffler
in the 2020 race which was not decided
on the day of general election however
there were some changes to the voting
process this time around
all right so
not a terribly surprising turn of events
another loss for republicans
just add it to the list
and this brings us back to the the blame
game the finger pointing who's at fault
what does it fault
and the answer is it's sort of all of
the above right all of the things that
people are pointing to
um all of that plays A Part mail-in
voting ballot harvesting yes obviously
that's part of the story here is always
also weak candidates you know we can't
get around that
probably that might not be the only
issue here it's not just a matter of
candidate quality but it is also that
um there were Republicans who won in
Georgia like Kemp for example
Herschel Walker didn't
and Herschel Walker is a celebrity
okay that's pretty much all that can be
said about him that's that's the only
argument anyone could ever make for him
is uh he's a celebrity
and then in the general election the
real argument is that well he's the
Republican he's better than Raphael
Warnock which of course he was but it's
like not hard to be better than Warnock
or any Democrat
so he was not a strong candidate he
didn't have any sort of track record
that would make anyone think he'd be a
good senator
he had loads of baggage he was not at
all good at articulating his ideas
just a weak candidate and that's and
that's an issue too
Republicans pick some very weak
candidates this time around every time
around
and it's not that every Republican who
lost was weak there were some there were
a few very strong Republicans very
impressive candidates who lost but
overall Canada quality is an issue
what's the solution to that well you
know Republican leadership needs to be
cleaned out everyone needs to be fired
but that's not happening it hasn't
happened so far
um usually the establishment of the
Republican Party they're rewarded for
their failures they're able to reward
themselves and that seems to be What's
Happening Here Again
Republicans need to master the ballot
harvesting and mail-in voting game but
there doesn't appear to be much will or
desire to do that either
because instead we'd rather stamp our
feet and talk about how unfair it is
and how much we don't like it and I
don't like it either
but we just have to decide do we want to
lose forever
or do do we want to win this is a choice
do you want to win or not
because you can't do it you have to win
first before you can do anything else
you want to reform the the uh our
elections
you want to make changes to the to the
way the elections are conducted you
can't do that unless you win you have to
win first to do anything you have to win
and you will not be able to win if you
don't Master the system as it's
currently in place if you don't learn
how to exploit this system as it's
currently in place you will just never
win and you could have your Purity as
you lose we could all lose and be very
pure in our in our losing and say we
stood on our principles we don't like
mail-in voting and ballot harvesting and
so we refuse to do it and so we just
lost forever Democrats took over
everything and that was it
so is that what we want we want to be do
we want to be the the pure hearted
losers
or do we want to be smart and cunning
um and uh and have our wits about us
and when
I hate bailing voting I hate ballot
harvesting you know how I feel about it
uh but it's here it's happening it's a
thing
and we also need better candidates too
but going forward you know this this
idea that uh whether it's Herschel
Walker or Oz
in Pennsylvania this idea that well
they're a celebrity so that means that
they you know that they'll they'll
cruise to Victory
hopefully
anyone who harbored this
uh
hallucinotary literary idea has been
disabused of that notion now
it's it just doesn't work that way no
one isn't yeah it the celebrity Factor
it really means less and less honestly
uh with each passing year
if this was 10 or 15 years ago it might
be a different story but but these days
I think actually the celebrity factor
means less than it ever has
because first of all nobody's impressed
with celebrities anymore like no one
cares it's just there there are a
million celebrities there are a million
famous people it doesn't mean anything
anymore
and uh and also because of the
overexposure all all of the politicians
immediately become celebrities anyway
I wish it wasn't that way they shouldn't
be but that's the way it goes because
the 24-hour cable news coverage at
social media and the internet just these
over exposure we see them all the time
we hear about them all the time and so
in effect they all become celebrities
um and and so it's just it's not if
that's what your
falling back on oh he's famous
it's not going to be enough
nobody cares it doesn't matter it's not
impressive
especially when it's someone who is
famous for being a football player you
know 25 years ago
nobody cares about that
no one cares about celebrity you know at
all really that's that's the honest
truth
um
all right
Joe Biden was uh speaking in Phoenix and
always has important uh things to say
it's important just to stay I think
informed about what the president United
States is talking about that's a very
important thing it's our civic duty so
let's check in with uh Biden
and today tsmc has announced a second
major investment that will construct a
second fab here in Phoenix to build
chips three Nano chips the three Nano
chip chips and a three Nano and you know
what I'm saying
Nano no no I don't know
oh okay well thank you Mr President that
was uh
so that's what he's up to
I think we can move on I also want to
mention this it's uh that time of the
year for Time Magazine to unveil it's
person of the year and you can if you
haven't seen the news yet just take a
guess who it is who's the person of the
year who's the the corporate media who
are they going to award person of the
year to
you'll never figure it out actually you
will you know you you guessed right
immediately zielinski obviously is there
a person of the year now of course the
title person of the year is meaningless
nobody really knows what it means what
is what does it mean to be person of the
year is it supposed to be the most
important person of the year the person
who has had the greatest impact on the
world
if that's the measuring stick then
zelenski obviously shouldn't be the guy
because the conflict in Ukraine has very
little impact on the rest of the world
it really doesn't affect anyone else
whether Ukraine is controlled by one
corrupt regime or the other it just like
for most of us it just doesn't mean
anything
um now zielinski has been trying to drag
the whole world into a global uh nuclear
conflict and that would certainly have
an impact
so maybe that's what they mean I don't
know besides if if this is just a matter
of giving the title to whoever has had
the most influence or you know for good
or ill
who's ever had the most influence
whoever's most altered world events or
whatever it is and and if that's the
case then you're going to select
somebody from the Russian Ukraine war
then shouldn't the guy be actually Putin
I mean that's for for the for the person
who just has had the most impact period
that's how that's how they used to
decide this right it wasn't a title
given to who they like the most but
rather just whoever has had the most
impact on the world good or bad
um
so that's what they would do but but
it's not anymore here's what it really
means person of the year award
is actually an award for the media
that's what it is now so time is
awarding itself it's awarding the media
um and the award actually says
this is the person that we in the media
were most interested in this year this
is the person that we made the biggest
deal about uh the person that we said
was the most important and we're always
right and so really it's an award to
themselves I mean they gave it they gave
it to Greta thunberg a couple of years
ago it made her the person of the year
perfect example it's just it's that's an
award to them like she's a she's a a a
media creation
and so they're giving it to her but
really it's it's about them they're
giving it to themselves
all right here's a an actual important
story The Daily wire has this report and
I can't read the whole thing but it's
worth going to uh daily wire
dot com to read this kind of a follow-up
from Luke rosiak it says a Virginia
grand jury investigating a public school
district's apparent cover-up of the rape
of a Girl by a male student in a girl's
bathroom which made headlines uh after a
daily wire investigation blasted school
officials for their stunning lack of
transparency and intentional Amnesia in
a much anticipated report released on
Monday and the fact-finding report that
nine person Loudoun County panel
disclosed for the first time that a
teacher's aide walked into the bathroom
while the ninth grade victim was being
raped by our male classmate saw two
pairs of feet under a stalled door but
did nothing
the 191-page report called out District
officials for a host of lapses
that's one way to put it that continued
long after the initial attack the report
stated quote we believe that throughout
this ordeal lcps administrators were
looking out for their own interests
instead of the best interest of lcps
this invariably led to a stunning lack
of openness transparency and
accountability both to the public and a
special ground jury grand jury the
report also found
that the district concealed the nature
of the attack even as the district was
trying to impose a controversial new
transgender bathroom policy after the
rape the student was transferred to
another school where he was involved in
multiple incidents of this Behavior
against girls that were known to
officials but until now unknown to the
public the report said even the rapist
on grandmother told officials that he
was a sociopath but little was done the
rapist soon committed another sexual
assault this time in a classroom the
grand jury report was released to inform
the public of its findings based on
subpoenaed documents and testimony
Virginia attorney general Jason Myers
noted in a statement that his office had
requested the grand jury and that it has
not been disbanded meaning it could
bring criminal charges at a later date
um The Daily y report that goes into the
details of the assault that that
happened in the bathroom this is on May
22nd of 2021
uh a male student wearing a skirt anally
raped a ninth grade girl in the girls
bathroom and uh we we knew obviously
about the rape because the daily wires
report
we didn't know that astute that a
teacher a faculty member
walked into the bathroom in the middle
of it and did nothing
um
the report reveals that in the days
before the bathroom rape a teacher's
assistant rode her department chair that
the student quote this is the rapist has
come into class more than once with his
arm around a girl's neck I've caught him
sitting on other girls laps several
times if this kind of Reckless Behavior
persists I wouldn't want to be held
accountable if somebody should get hurt
so she
wrote this
note to a department chair and then a
few days later this person committed a
rape in one of the bathrooms
um school officials seem more interested
in getting the teacher's aid in trouble
than the student the department chair
questioned the true motivation of the
author
uh the report said the department chair
mentioned the email to an assistant
principal who questioned whether the
author of the email had followed proper
protocol
um and then it goes on to more details
about
what exactly happened uh the the
victim's father shows up to the school
after he finds out what's happened and
he obviously is you know I don't think
words could properly describe a father's
feeling after finding out that their
daughter had been raped but he was you
know to put it a lightly Furious
and uh they're more interested in just
like getting him out of there and and he
was stonewalled and and uh then
infamously eventually arrested at a
school board meeting
it says by 3 30 PM of that same day
loudoun's Chief Operating Officer had
arrived at the school and sent an email
to the superintendent saying
quote the incident at sphs is related to
policy 8 uh 80 40 a policy that would
allow transgender males the right to use
the girl's bathroom
now as I said you you got to go and read
the whole report I mean it says what was
the consequence for this um
for this it says on September 9th 2021
just two weeks into the school year
uh the rapist grabbed the shoulder of a
girl really hard in class tried to take
her computer and asked if she posted
nudes online
the superintendent Deputy superintendent
and superintendent Chief of Staff All
learned at this incident
and knew it was the same individual who
committed the sexual assault at sphs
despite having
a 12-page disciplinary file wearing an
ankle monitor being closely monitored by
the Broad Run principal knowledge of
assistant by the highest administrator
in LSP lcps and a suggestion by the
court services unit that a more serious
punishment be given the rapist was
simply asked to write the following
I will not touch others
I will not ask for photos to include
intimate or provocative
because this was after he committed the
rape was transferred to another school
he's still being aggressive sexually
aggressive with with female students
this is all known his history is known
and after another incident his
punishment is writing that note
and that was it
you know we heard from the left after
Luke rosiak's initial expose that this
case had nothing to do with the bathroom
policies they're looking for ways to
frantically kind of
uh get around all of this and one thing
that they said is that this is nothing
to do with bathroom policies at all and
yet
here we have school officials admitting
privately in writing that the two issues
are indeed related because obviously
they are
there's a there's a rape in your in your
school by a male student in the female
bathroom
and yet you're still pushing through a
policy
that would open up the female bathrooms
to any boy that wants to walk in
obviously it's related but it's about
more than that this is a systemic
failure um fueled by
woke Insanity along with cowardice
incompetence self-preservation
selfishness all the factors that allow
these kinds of things to happen within
institutions
um in fact sex abuse in institutions
whether it's the Catholic church or
Hollywood or the public school system
they always follow the same script
you've got some people lower down the
ladder who notice the problem try to
bring attention to it the teacher's aid
in this case they're stonewalled by the
bureaucracy the problem is covered up
predators are just like transferred from
one place to another they bounce bounce
around it's like this game of hot potato
between the various uh you know
institutions because nobody wants to
deal with it
and it's always the same story
we have to eventually deal with the fact
that this issue in Loudoun
is indeed part of a systemic
problem something that is endemic within
the public school system
that's the next step here
as some of us have been shouting about
for years
you know there there is a there is a
system-wide sex abuse epidemic in the
public school system it has been going
on for literally decades the Department
of Education itself acknowledged the
problem back in 2004
okay and uh and nothing has been done
about it
so this is this is just
you know this is tip of the iceberg
stuff
and this kind of thing can only happen
in in an institution that has this sort
of systemic problem
eventually we have to we have to deal
with that and you would think that we as
a as a society would be very would be
very um
eager to confront the sex abuse problem
in this public school system considering
that that 50 million kids are in the
system
it's like millions of of us not me but
millions of of us millions of Americans
send our kids in this system every
single day
you think if there's evidence you think
of the Department of Education
themselves
nearly 20 years ago acknowledge that
there is a massive problem of sex abuse
in the school system sex abuse committed
by teachers and sex abuses committed by
students against other students
you'd think that we would we would we
would uh wake up and pay attention
and you have millions of parents saying
my God this is what you know my kid is
potentially being subjected to this
but said we've been uh looking the other
way
all right
lives of tick tock has this it's a video
giving
teachers tips on how to make classrooms
more trans inclusive because that of
course is should be our goal let's
listen to this
hi I'm Jack my pronouns are they them
and I identify as trans and non-binary
here are three things you can do to
support trans children in your school
number one be a visible trans Ally there
are lots of ways to do this from having
trans-inclusive Flags in your classroom
to having trans inclusive storybooks on
your bookshelves number two stop
unnecessarily gendering things in your
school this ranges from Easy changes
like not grouping children into boys and
girls to not having gendered uniforms
consider how it's glueded trans and
especially non-binary children and staff
may feel about gendered spaces and
policies and number three teach children
about pronouns what they are how we use
them and why they're important this
allows trans people to not be singled
out for their pronouns and instead makes
pronouns part of the norm
you know we can make all the usual
points here that this is uh this is not
what schools are supposed to do this is
not what the classroom is for this is
not education this is a form of
religious indoctrination to promote
transgenderism in the class as a
violation of the separation of church
and state that we always
hear about it's a violation of many
other things as well but it is also
religious indoctrination
um
but rather than dwelling on those points
this time I want to make a a different
observation because there's one thing
you said that jumped out at Me Maybe
slightly subtle I don't know if you
picked up on it
amid all the the usual insanity
he said especially non-binary kids
especially so he's talking about the
challenges faced by quote trans and
non-binary kids even though there are no
such thing as trans and non-binary kids
or adults for that matter
but he's discussing the challenges or or
whatever and he says especially
non-binary
and that's because there's a there's a
shift happening we should we should take
note of this there is a shift happening
at the top of the victim pyramid
and we've talked about the victim
pyramid many times on on this show this
is the victim hierarchy there is a
hierarchy of victimhood on the left and
there's always there's there's this
Perpetual jostling and the war at the
top like who's the Uber victim
um what group can claim status as the
Uber super victims
and if you're if you're at that uh if
you're at the top of the victim
hierarchy it means that it's kind of
almost an inverted hierarchy because it
means that you cannot be guilty of
victimizing anyone else but everyone is
always victimizing you
and victim mode is power so it means
that you have power it's very it's a
very inverted upside down sort of
topsy-turvy
system but that's the system so there's
this but right now there's this uh
there's a this shift happening where
non-binary is slowly replacing trans as
the most favored most protected most
cherished group in fact here's a
prediction for you I I think that trans
as a category will fade away
like the category of lesbian has all but
disappeared as as you know because
lesbians been subsumed by trans
and uh and the same thing's gonna happen
with trans I think trans gets subsumed
by non-binary eventually it's just it
all is simply non-binary now in effect
it's the same thing it's the same brand
of insanity there's no real difference
they're both made up they're both making
essentially the same false claim but the
advantage of non-binary is that it's
even more vague it's even more
undefinable it's even more
subjective than trans
so trans still ties itself from one
thing to the very gender binary that
it's supposedly be that it's supposedly
trying to dismantle non-binary is meant
to be apart from that entirely and the
great thing for non-binary is that there
are no expectations attached to it
there's no definitions there's just like
nothing at all
it means even less than trans
and trans when you get down to it really
doesn't mean anything either of course
but but but non-binary is even more
undefinable even more uh
absurd and vague and uh it can just be
whatever you want it to be which makes
it more useful to the left it's a more
useful category
the more vague the more undefinable the
more ambiguous the category is the more
useful it is to them
so more and more that's what we're going
to start to see
it's like trans trans becomes passe it
becomes old-fashioned and the new thing
is to be non-binary
all right what else have we got um
before I get to the comment section okay
there's one other
one from live The Tick Tock well not
from her but reposted by her and to be
clear
and I wanted to play this too because
there's another important point so
here's a tick tocker explaining
what you need to do if you want to
invite your white friend to hang out so
this is really for if you're non-white
and you want to bring your white friend
along for a hangout session
there's a process that needs to be
followed and let's listen to that
controversial opinion but if you have a
token white and you're hanging out with
your friend group of color
you need to ask permission from
everybody in the group to bring your
white friend like don't just bring them
ask for explicit permission from
everyone because just because you're
comfortable with them doesn't mean that
everybody's comfortable with them I
might not be in the mood to deal with
white shenanigans that day that's that's
all I'm saying and another thing it
feeds into their ego like don't don't
let them think they're a good white
person don't don't give them that card
to use against other people please don't
do that
to me this doesn't go nearly far enough
and the real problem is that it puts the
onus on a member of the bipod Community
to seek permission on behalf of the
white friend which I think is
unacceptable like what needs to happen
is the white friend who wishes to
accompany a POC friend to a POC
Gathering must himself or herself or
herself submit
a written request form no less than 14
days before the gathering this this
request should be signed it should be
notarized it should include three
professional references and two personal
references of course I'll you know let's
say 135 dollar processing fee as well
that's the bare minimum
there should also be an essay explaining
how you are an ally and why you're safe
and uh you know how it is that you pose
no threat to the POC members of the
engagement that you're attending
that's what needs to happen
but keep in mind that that claiming
you're an ally and that you're safe is
itself racist as it denies the reality
of inherent white racism and it shows
that you haven't really done the work
of course if you don't say that you're
an ally and that you're safe then it
must also be assumed that you're neither
of those things
so your race is by the way just remember
that and remember too that it's
necessary for you to seek permission
yet also seeking permission is racist
because it centers you as the white
person
it may be best to just I guess stay at
home and try not to hang out you know
don't try to hang out with any POC
individuals in the first place then
again
staying home and refusing to congregate
with non-white people is segregation and
otherization
and marginalization and that's also
racist
so to review seek permission or else
you're racist
but don't seek permission because that's
racist declare yourself non-racist or
else you're racist but also you're
racist if you claim to be not racist
try to be an ally or else you're not an
ally and thus you're racist but also
trying to be an ally is racist
I hope this clarifies the situation for
everybody
I think the real conclusion here is just
to not give the slightest damn if anyone
calls you racist
in fact that's that's actually the only
way out they've given us that's that's
the only possible door to take and uh so
we should gladly say well I'll take that
option then fine with me
all right let's get to the comment
section
[Music]
[Applause]
cruise to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
if you're listening to this show odds
are that you put a lot of stock in how
you raise your kids you understand that
your children look to you to Define
their values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property as well it
lays out your Healthcare power of
attorney to ensure that your end of life
decisions are carried out so if you're
just starting out you don't have
thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you uh want to make sure
that your savings your belongings and
your family are all protected well epic
will is perfect for you you have to
create your will at epicwill.com Epic
Wills early estate plans started just
119 bucks and you can save 10 percent
when you use promo code Walsh go to
epicwill.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 percent on Epic Will's complete
will package that's epicwill.com promo
code Walsh
Miguel says I was a part of a popular
cover band in my native country of
Jamaica no one or no law could make us
perform at a gay wedding there are
certain questions we would ask before we
accept a gig namely what type of event
who will be at the event and so on if we
found out it's gay wedding as we did
once we would just decline case closed
we have nothing against gay people as
I'm sure we've performed at many venues
where gay people were in attendance a
gay event and a general event where gays
are attendance are two totally different
things y equals MX plus C it's simple
well Miguel
you confused me with the math equation
at the end I was with you the whole way
I was saying amen and then and then I'm
confused
um but I'm with you and all the rest of
it
Aaron Bell says the wedding photographer
for my husbands and and my wedding uh
retired early because he knew he might
end up being asked to do a gay wedding
he knew if he refused he would be
screwed there are a lot of cases like
this I've heard very similar situations
people not getting into the wedding
business to begin with OR getting out of
it
um I know of you know personally someone
who owned a a venue that had been used
for weddings got out of the business
for exactly this reason
um
and of course the left hears that and
they think you know they're they're
they're rubbing their hands together and
saying yeah our plan is working good
this is this is part of the point
uh goat says I'm white and I'm proud of
it
no no that's that's racist don't you
realize you can be proud of being black
or Asian Or Hispanic or gay you could be
proud of any race other than white just
so you can be proud of any sexuality
other than being straight
then you know that those are the rules
how can the rules be justified or
defended I mean they can't obviously
um
Tim says the Civil Rights Act needs to
be repealed since it wasn't clear to the
courts that it was addressed to the
public sector not the private sector
it's been used increasingly and
illegally against the private sector
since its Inception if a business
doesn't want to serve whatever minority
or whatever group they don't have to and
they have the right to announce it
well it was meant to be addressed to the
private sector
um
that's the whole point but
I agree that businesses should have the
right to serve who they want that's it
that's all
um as we've been talking about for the
last few days
just give give businesses the right
that's the that's the easiest solution
here
um there are other Solutions there are
other ways of uh kind of splitting the
hairs here so that you are protecting
the uh the religious liberty of
photographers and Bakers and all the
rest of it
um
you know you you can parse these kinds
of cases
but the simplest and easiest and most
sensible thing is just to say
you know serve whoever you want don't
serve whoever you want the market will
respond
and if you make a decision in that
regard
uh where you decide I'm going to exclude
certain races from my restaurant or
whatever if anybody would would do that
that would be suicidal to their business
and they'd go out of business and that's
it they just announced themselves and
then they go out of business
all right
Margot says I can tell that Matt has
experienced a narcissist up close and
personal for a duration because he knows
exactly how narcissists are spot on
description I actually haven't I just
live in a culture dominated by them
that's all that I've I've noticed
BD says after that black pink analysis I
want Matt as my English teacher ASAP
Grant says only Matt could actually make
black pink lyrics sound like actual
wisdom djm beautiful interpretation of
the black pink lyric I'm in tears thank
you Matt uh many many comments like this
and I appreciate everyone's you know I
wasn't sure uh if the audience
If there really was any desire in the
audience to hear my in-depth analysis of
K-pop
songs but uh it was something that came
from the heart you know and I felt I
felt compelled to talk about it and I'm
very relieved to find out that it
resonated with so many people
finally Vicki says Matt I saw on your
wife's Twitter that Ben Shapiro was
expecting another baby do you think
he'll catch up to you yeah apparently
Ben announced that on all on on all
access so I don't think I'm stealing his
Thunder here it's already on Twitter
they are expecting their fourth will he
catch up to me well we've done we've
done the two for one special twice now
so uh we're reproducing much more
efficiently
he's gonna have to start doubling up I
think if he wants to beat me in the race
but honestly let's not discount there's
a dark horse in the race here which is
uh in the in the daily wire repopulation
contest there's also Michael Knowles you
know because they uh they had a kid and
then somehow like a month and a half
later they had another kid so they're
they're going at a pretty good clip
I still feel like we're safe though with
six
look at it this way between me Ben and
Michael that's 12 kids so far
so I think between the three of us
we have more children than the entire
rest of the media combined most likely
this is how serious we are about about
uh reversing the population trends
it's also how serious we are about
driving daily wire memberships because
we will literally conceive new daily
wire members if that's what it takes
it's hard to believe that the holidays
are already here now I know a lot of you
are already daily wire Plus members and
get to enjoy the great content that we
have released this year like Tara on the
Prairie the greatest lie ever sold and
my very own documentary what is a woman
for those of you who haven't been able
to enjoy it because you're not a member
well now is the time to take advantage
of the 30 holiday sale this discount
also applies to gift memberships so
don't miss this opportunity to get
everyone on your list an annual gift
membership from daily wire plus with
code holiday at checkout since joining
Delaware plus Jordan Peterson has been
on fire with tons of content most
recently Jordan went with our production
team to Washington DC filmed a fantastic
documentary on the Museum of the Bible
called logos and literacy in it Jordan
meets with historians theologians and
philosophers to discuss the history of
the Bible and its influence on the world
it's as beautiful as it is engaging
Jordan even sent us a note to say how
happy he was with the way it turned out
he watched it twice as much he liked it
so remember this content is only
available for daily wire Plus members so
sign up today use code holiday at
checkout to get 30 percent off your new
annual daily wire plus membership at
dailywire.com
walls.dailywire.com Walsh today now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
now I wasn't following the controversy
this week or rather last week very close
because there are only so many
controversies you can follow at any
given moment for those who are out of
this particular loop as well it turns
out that the elderly owner of the Dallas
Cowboys Jerry Jones
was in the vicinity of a racist
occurrence 65 years ago when he was 14.
the picture surfaced of Jones who's now
I think about 80 years old standing in a
in a large crowd outside of North Little
Rock High School while a group of white
students attempted to block a group of
black students from entering the
building
this was again over half a century ago
there is no evidence that Jones himself
was trying to prevent the desegregation
of his school he was merely in the area
where such efforts were happening
um and he was like looking on curiously
even if a 14 year old Jerry Jones 65
years ago
actually was opposed to desegregation
even if he did participate in the human
blockade to prevent it that would still
have no bearing on today
when he was if it's 65 years ago when
he's 14 it would be completely absurd to
try and hold an old man accountable for
failing to have racially enlightened
views as an adolescent in the 1950s
the whole controversy is ludicrous and
yet it raged on with the media trying to
make something out of a non-scandle
um though it was never clearly precisely
clear what they wanted to make out of it
exactly what is Jerry Jones supposed to
do about the picture retire in disgrace
because there were racist people in his
high school in 1957.
should he go up to Canada and have
himself euthanized
now I'm sure the race-baiting rage mob
would greatly appreciate either of those
gestures especially the second one but
uh it won't accomplish much for that to
happen except to provide more sick
satisfaction to sadist with a fetish for
humiliating random people for no
apparent reason
it was at least an opportunity for The
Usual Suspects to get up on their soap
boxes LeBron James found a way as he
always does to make himself the story
here to make himself actually the victim
he expressed deep hurt and offense that
the Sports reporters at a post-game
press conference last week hadn't asked
him
about this hadn't given him the chance
to uh opine on this subject here's what
he said
I was wondering why I haven't gotten a
question from you guys about the Jerry
Jones Photo
but when the Kyrie thing was going on
you guys were quick to ask us questions
about that
okay
um hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on and I don't even want you guys to say
nothing
when I watched Kyrie talk and he says I
know who I am
but I want to keep the same energy
when we're talking about my people and
the things we've been through
and
that Jerry Jones Photo
is one of those moments
that our people black people have been
through in America
and I feel like
it's a black man as a black athlete as
someone with power and a platform
when we do something wrong
or or something that people don't agree
with
so every single tabloid
every single news coverage it's on the
bottom ticker it's asked about every
single day
but it seems like to me that the whole
Jerry Jones
situation photo and I know it was years
and years ago and we all make mistakes I
get it
but it seemed like it's just been buried
under like oh it happened okay we just
we just move on
and I was just kind of disappointed I
haven't received that question from you
guys
appreciate it
uh just for the record by the way LeBron
he uh he immediately threw Kyrie Irving
under the bus and condemned him for
harming people
so you know this this is what a what a
fraud
this guy is
but now he wants to be asked
non-basketball questions
um but he wants to pick which questions
he's asked
because the thing with Kyrie Irving is
like he's a basketball player
uh he's played with LeBron so it kind of
makes sense for him to be asked about it
Jerry Jones is uh the owner of the
Dallas Cowboys which is an entirely
different sport
but as clay Travis pointed out last week
you never see him you know complaining
that he isn't asked enough questions
about I don't know China's human rights
violations
no he only wants the easy questions he
wants the ones that Tee him up to
deliver a little pre-planned speech
or else he wants you to ask him about
the books that he's pretending to read
That's the other subject he loves to
talk about speaking of Usual Suspects
Jameel Hill took to the pages of the
Atlantic to search for the deeper
significance of the Jerry Jones story
this is what she said if you're
wondering why in professional football
so few black coaches get hired and black
players struggle to be heard you can
learn a lot from a 65 year old image of
Jerry Jones in a 1957 photo published
late last month by The Washington Post
the future owner of the Dallas Cowboys
then 14 stood among a group of white
teenagers who were blocking six black
students from desegregating his Arkansas
High School in an interview with the
post Jones minimized his role in the
event quote I don't know uh that I or
anybody anticipated or had a background
of knowing what was involved it was more
a Curious Thing Jones told the newspaper
which has published a series of stories
about the NFL's failures to promote
black coaches over the course of decades
Jones is a sophomore at North Little
Rock High when the photo was taken you
could argue that Jones was only a kid
but as an adult he hasn't adequately
reflected on what his presence in a
crowd of hostile white teens would have
meant to black students and he hasn't
fundamentally disavowed the narrow
bigoted attitudes that once surrounded
him and are still a force in football
today
yes Jones's Reflections are not adequate
by Jamil's standards
the woman who has never engaged in
anything resembling introspection or
self-criticism is here to tell the rest
of us what adequate introspection and
self-criticism looks like
she also claims that racism is still a
force in football today which is like
saying that I don't know diet culture is
a force at Golden Corral if there's any
racism in the NFL it would have to go
the other way seeing as how the NFL
disproportionately hires black people
and turns them into famous millionaires
that's what the NFL does
this of course isn't really about racism
in the NFL it's about the race-baders
desperately Clinging On to past sins
past grievances past injustices uh even
and especially the ones that they were
not around for
nothing is allowed to change no
individual is allowed to change the past
is never in the past there is no past
there is only an eternal present and all
that ever happened is somehow still
happening and will never stop happening
time is a flat circle
there is no forgiveness in their world
there is no Redemption
they claim to be working for improvement
in progress in society but their
ideology precludes that nothing gets
better nobody grows or learns every
wound remains fresh and bleeding forever
because that's what they want
this is essentially the argument for
reparations which the state of
California by the way is working towards
implementing their reparations task
force assembled by Gavin Newsom is now
kicking around figures as high as a
quarter of a million dollars for each
black resident
but how can this even be accomplished if
the idea is to pay reparations to the
descendants of slaves
will they conduct genealogy tests ahead
of time to distinguish from you know the
uh the the descendants of African slaves
and the descendants of African slave
Traders and slave owners of which there
were many are we going to distinguish
between those two what about black
people whose families came to this
country many years after slavery was
abolished
what about those whose ancestors were
wealthy slave owners in Africa and then
came to America after emancipation
what about those who are mixed race half
white and half black
do they pay reparations to themselves
and what about white people who are
descended from those enslaved in
Northern Africa or who came here as
indentured servants or who came here
long after slavery and experienced
bigotry and Prejudice of Their Own
any reparations plan would have to be
able to make these distinctions before
it could even begin to claim any sort of
ethical rationale yet no reparations
plan including this one grapples with
any of this
all the black people are in effect
considered slavery descendants whether
they really are or not and all the white
people are considered descendants of
slave owners whether they really are or
not it's it's unconscionably stupid and
unjust
of course that's not to say that I would
favor reparations for the actual
descendants of slavery whoever and
wherever they are uh because it's been
150 years it's been a century and a half
since the practice was abolished
there's been many generations to recover
from the trauma
and if you're still somehow feeling
persecuted by a form of persecution that
you didn't experience and your parents
didn't experience and your grandparents
and grandparents grandparents an
experience then it's it's probably
because you want to feel persecuted
this again is how the left's racial
ideology works
minority groups are encouraged to hold
on to grudges for centuries nothing is
allowed to change nothing is allowed to
get better nobody is allowed to move on
ever not after a decade not after two
decades not after 15 decades
it's just not possible to have a
functioning much less thriving society
that is built this way governed by
generational resentment and blood libel
and scars that are perpetually reopened
again and again because nobody is
interested in allowing them to heal
you can't even have a functional family
when there's a Perpetual resentment you
know fault finding every argument
devolves into a relitigation of wrongs
committed in the ancient past
a marriage that's plagued by Petty
bitterness like that and
grievance-mongering will collapse
and quickly if there isn't a change
so how does this work when we extend it
out to an entire Society
how can a country survive if our
arguments cannot go anywhere because
they can't move past the events of the
mid 19th century
it can't survive that's the answer it's
not intended to survive that's the point
after all it's a destructive agenda
by Design
and that's why those behind the agenda
are once again today canceled and I'll
do it for this portion of the show as we
move over to the members block hope to
see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]